>>> A FEDERAL JUDGE RULED TO
LIFT ALL RESTRICTIONS ON JOHN
HINCKLEY JR., THE MAN WHO TRIED
TO ASSASSINATE PRESIDENT REAGAN.
THIS MORNING I'M JOINED BY TIM
McCARTHY, THE SECRET SERVICE
AGENT WHO TOOK A BULLET WHILE
PROTECTING REAGAN DURING THE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT 40 YEARS
AGO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING, TIM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
OBVIOUSLY, THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
APPRECIATES THE WORK YOU DID
THEN AND FOR YOUR ENTIRE LIFE.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
HEARD HE HAS BEEN GRANTED HIS
COMPLETE RELEASE AS OF THIS
COMING JUNE?
>> WELL, I WAS SLIGHTLY
SURPRISED AND A BIT DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DIDN'T CONSULT WITH -- I
SHOULDN'T SAY CONSULT.
AT LEAST ADVISE ME THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO OBJECT TO IT.
SO FORGIVE ME IF I DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF GOOD CHRISTIAN THOUGHTS
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO ALMOST SHOT
ME, MADE MY WIFE A WIDOW AND MY
CHILDREN WOULDN'T HAVE HAD A
FATHER, I DON'T SEE REVENGE
EITHER AS A CHRISTIAN.
THIS IS BEHIND ME.
BUT LET'S KEEP IN MIND THE
CONTEXT OF THIS.
THIS WAS A MASS SHOOTING BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEFINITION.
ONE MAN WAS KILLED.
JIM BRADY WAS MURDERED.
FROM THE TIME HE WAS SHOT, HIS
FAMILY WAS RUINED.
HIS RECOVERY -- THERE NEVER WAS
MUCH RECOVERY.
TOM DELAHANE SHOT IN THE BACK OF
THE NECK AND HIS CAREER
DESTROYED AFTER THAT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT CONTEXT IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WHEN A PRESIDENT IS ELECTED, HE
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE BALLOT BOX OR
IMPEACHMENT.
AND PRESIDENT REAGAN, LIKE MOST
PRESIDENTS, WAS VERY
CONSEQUENTIAL IN THE THINGS HE
DID AND THE AGENDA HE HAD AND
WHAT HE DID DURING HIS EIGHT
YEARS.
THAT MAY HAVE CHANGED.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
WHEN A PRESIDENT IS ELECTED, HE
SHOULD SERVE HIS TERM.
WE RELEASED SIR HAND SIR HAND
SOUNDS AS IF HE MAY BE RELEASED
OVER OBJECTIONS BY MANY IN THE
KENNEDY FAMILY.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T MINIMIZE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD,
THAT -- IT'S NOT AN EASY TARGET.
BUT HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GOING TO
SECOND-GUESS THE JUDGE BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HE KNOWS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PSYCHIATRISTS HAVE SAID.
I KNOW WHAT THEY SAID.
HE'S NO LONGER A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS.
BUT THEY BETTER BE RIGHT.
HE BETTER BE RIGHT.
WE CAN'T HAVE OUR PRESIDENTS AND
EVEN PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
BEING THE OBJECT OF ASSAULTS AND
MURDER SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE THEIR POLITICS.
.
>>
WHEN SHE GOT THE NEWS, THE SAME
NEWS YOU GOT AND WERE SURPRISED
BY IT, HE'S GETTING AN
UNCONDITIONAL RELEASE.
SHE SAID NOW HINCKLEY'S LAST
RESTRICTIONS HAVE BEEN LIFTED,
HE CAN NOW IF HE WANTS CONTACT
ME, MY SIBLINGS AND THE ACTRESS
JODIE FOSTER, WHO IS AS IS WELL
KNOWN HE WAS TRYING TO IMPRESS
BY CARRYING OUT HIS AMBUSH.
HE COULD KNOCK ON YOUR DOOR.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T
FEAR FOR MY SAFETY OR MY
FAMILY'S SAFETY, AND HE WOULD BE
A VERY BAD IDEA FOR HIM TO SHOW
UP ON MY FRONT PORCH, I ASSURE
YOU OF THAT.
IT WOULD NOT BE WELCOME.
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING.
YOU KNOW, THAT -- THAT THEIR
FATHER WAS ALMOST KILLED.
PUT THEIR FAMILY THROUGH A LOT
OF TRAUMA.
BUT AND AS MUCH AS I APPRECIATE
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY, THE
BIGGER PICTURE IN MY VIEW IS WE
CAN'T ALLOW OR GIVE ANY PEOPLE
ANY IDEA THAT TAKING A SHOT AT
THE PRESIDENT IS ANYTHING LESS
THAN THE MOST SEVERE, SHOULD GET
THE MOST SEVERE PUNISHMENT.
NOT NECESSARILY JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE NO LONGER A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS, BUT CAN WE
TAKE THIS RISK CONSTANTLY.
LOOK HOW MANY PRESIDENTS WE HAD
ATTEMPTED ASSASSINATIONS ON OR
ASSASSINATIONS.
CAN WE CONTINUE IT TAKE THAT
RISK AND SEND A MESSAGE THAT
MAYBE, OKAY, YOU CAN DO IT AND
MAYBE YOU DO 25 OR 30 YEARS AND
YOU'RE OUT.
SO I WORRY ABOUT WHAT IT SAYS IN
THE GREATER CONTEXT ABOUT
PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE GO THROUGH OUR ELECTIONS, OUR
ARE SOMETHING TO BEHOLD, AS YOU
KNOW.
THEY'RE CONTENTIOUS AND THEY'RE
THOROUGH AND WE GO THROUGH ALL
THIS TO ELECT A PRESIDENT, AND
THEN WE, YOU KNOW, DISCOUNT THE
FACT THAT IT IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD, THE PERSON WHO HAS
THE NUCLEAR ARMS UNDER THEIR
CONTROL.
SO IT IS THE BIGGER CONTEXT THAT
I SEE AND I HOPE THEY'RE RIGHT
ABOUT HINCKLEY.
HE SHOULD NOT COME TO MY FRONT
DOOR AS YO